I'd like to start with Dede hello Deedee
hello hi
so your friend Francis McDormand also in
the film producing partner she bought
the rights to Miriam's book
and she has said that in her first
meeting with you you were so prepared
that you brought diagrams and I'd love
to know what was in those diagrams and
what did you talk about in that meeting
that that made you feel like yes we are
going to make this film she's such a
snitch
um I uh I drew the colony and all the
stories of the colony and made sketches
of all the
I don't know why I just loved it and I
and I felt like I needed to um animate
it and so I taped all these pages from
my journal together and made this big
sheet of paper and just drew the entire
thing
um
and I just found it the other day
because I gave my daughter the book
um sorry what was the question I was
just wondering first of all what was in
the diagrams which you just said and
what did you walk away with as a shared
Vision after that conversation with Fran
did because this isn't the easiest story
to bring to the screen and make it
compelling and watchable and not a
chamber piece of theater but something
made for Cinema so what what had the two
of you agreed on that that aggrandized
you to really push forward
I never questioned that it could be
cinematic I think it's visually
cinematic but I also think it's
structurally cinematic like I Know How
It Ends I know what incites it I know
I know how to map it you know
um
I think we just thought let's shoot for
the moon and try uh I didn't see why not
to try I figured like if 12 Angry Men
can do it so can they eat women
um Ben amazing work as always
um the lone male among so many
incredible women and what an honor I'm
sure that was
in in researching the book I was
interested to know that August is
actually the narrator in the book your
character is the narrator which is a
pretty big shift and I'm glad you made
that shift I think it was very smart
as as a male artist who's worked in film
television theater
how did it feel for you to be in the
presence of all of these women and tell
this story and how did it change you as
an artist
it felt amazing and it was just a joy
um
it was very
it's sort of hard to describe but it was
um I experienced it as very
there was no competition going on or
it wasn't complicated it was
straightforward and it was gentle and it
was focused and it was
um
funny and
um
so it was it was really a privilege I I
well I was I would call home to
girlfriend's home and was like this is
so crazy being
and so crazy because it's so unusual so
rare to be in a in a situation like
being the only man in uh
um among so many women and um and and so
um
I don't know I just was like
basically women are much better
I wish I'd always known but um but it
was very much confirmed that's amazing
and Hilder another amazing piece of art
from you this and Tara in the same year
just really staggering incredible
but obviously she's not talking about
Tara tonight
um I read something funny that Sarah has
said about you which is quote you are
incapable of sentimentality which I
think is a really interesting thing to
say about someone and after scoring
sicario and Joker I can sort of
understand why she's saying those things
and for which you won an Oscar for Joker
so congratulations on that
yes amazing
and it's it for me it seems the score in
this film isn't so much about sentiment
as it is about hopefulness it's like
this constant reminder that things
aren't always going to be this bad it
kind of comes in and there's a harbinger
of good things to come but then you also
had the challenge in the flashbacks to
call us back to those horrible moments
with the bells which is just so chilling
so tell me about the process of settling
on that sort of binary approach and what
experimentation you had to do along the
way
um
yeah
well
um we had a bit of a back and forth to
find the right
um
the right tone for the movie because I I
think and like originally
when I first you know when I when I
first read the script and and I um and I
researched uh what happened to these
women I was just so angry I was so angry
and I was so sad that I just I literally
got paralyzed for for a few days and I
just I just cried for for this and I was
just like how do I even begin to write
music that that
that even begins to to touch on what
these women went through you know and
and I found that um
it was quite challenging for me and in
the in the beginning and
um
and it's it's probably that the darkest
story that I worked on and I worked on
some pretty dark [ __ ]
um Rooney congratulations again another
amazing performance
um I feel like so much hopefulness is
embedded in your character
even as she's on the precipice of having
a baby that was you know created out of
the worst possible circumstances
and it's almost like she herself
represents that doomsday or and a call
to prayer at the same time there's
something beautiful going on but it's
it's very extreme
and she's so matter of fact too I love
that about her she's so practical and
she'll say things like even the animals
are safer in their homes than we are and
she says it with almost like a lightness
which is just so fascinating
and I'm wondering how much of this
optimism and practicality that we see in
her is resignation and how did you play
that emotion in preparing this character
I don't I don't I don't know I've never
thought about that I don't know how much
of it is resignation that's not how I
how I thought of it
um I think Ona is
you know I think she's been an outsider
in this community for most of her life
she's different than everyone
um and yet I think she
um
even though she is sort of an outsider
and a rebel in a sense she has such a
steadfast faith and such a love for
these women and for her community
um which is rare to be like an outsider
and a rebel but to still you know hold
your community close in that way and
also what Rebel means in that context
yeah you know even just veering a little
outside of the lines would earn her that
title
yeah I think she's living her life in
her own way but
um for herself not to make any sort of
statement I think she just has a
a really high level of Consciousness
um and
a lot of empathy and sensitivity and and
a great capacity
um to love because of because of all
those things and I think she is really
hopeful and
um
yeah and the blessings come sort of in
unexpected ways which I think is a
difficult thing to process but it's it's
quite beautiful and thank you for your
work
and Claire
um I read an interview that you gave
during the early promotion cycle of the
film at the festivals and you said
something really interesting which is
cautioning people to not see this movie
through the lens of me too or sort of
current our current movement Reckoning
whatever it is we're undergoing at the
moment and you said quote this story is
basically as old as time and I couldn't
agree with you more
and that made me think about religion
and how much religion has fomented these
types of structures that have hurt women
over the years
and I'm wondering do you think women can
ever possibly be free in a system like
this A system that has created the types
of men who would then hurt them in such
horrible ways do you think that exists
for women within the confines of this
belief system
hard question haven't I
I'm glad to say oh for me
um I don't know is the answer I don't
live in a devoutly religious community I
am not devoutly religious myself it was
extraordinary to to research and and for
a very small tiny moment live in a world
where these women were in the process of
separating religion and faith
um and separating their existence from
what they knew to be their faith and
their reality I think a garther in the
movie is very good and owner is as well
about separating those two things and
helping the women to understand that
there is a difference and that their
their faith has been manipulated and
used against them
um almost seems like faith in each other
and Community yeah and that they're
they're going in towards something where
they can reimagine what that is for
themselves so I really don't know I
think freedom and the freedom of women
and the freedom of any group of people
that have been oppressed
um is something that I feel like is very
much
coming to ahead now and we're realizing
how deep rooted those problems are and I
just always want to you know caution
about against imagining that that's
going to be a simple path
um not that I you know having it you
know not I know anything but I just
think that then it can be washed away
like the knowledge of something doesn't
necessarily mean it's healed I don't
think we don't have a ton of time
tonight obviously so I'll close with
Sarah
um and I just want to know how it feels
for you to be on the other side of all
of this creative female imagination
this active female imagination and are
you able to fully appreciate this effort
that you have undertaken
I mean because it was such a collective
and such a collaborative effort yes I'm
able to be
um just feeling really great about the
process in a way that I wouldn't if it
was more you know the the act of a
single Vision but I had so such amazing
input at every stage and so many people
who brought all of themselves and their
lived experience to the table so I get
to
kind of appreciate and be grateful for
all of that which is amazing but even
you know I was just thinking even
details like something that becomes
memorable for somebody like you you
brought up doomsday and a call to prayer
and you know that's a line of voice over
but that's actually the way Hilder
described the bells when she sent them
to me that's a line from her about her
score that ended up in the voiceover so
when I see the film I'm able to kind of
see all of our
all of these little tendrils of
different people's
thoughts and dreams in the film and so
you're sort of able to be proud of it in
a different way than if it was just your
voice and that's been thrilling and you
created an environment where you
everyone knew that what they had to say
was was welcomed and valued that's huge
just this group created that you know
that was like a community of people who
all were able to step out
she's Canadian I know she doesn't like
to take credit for things but well
that's very clear and even just being
backstage with you so much laughter and
joy it's clear that you have a very
special connection and it shows and
thank you so much for making this movie
we really appreciate it thank you for
coming out tonight have a wonderful
evening thank you
[Applause]